nelson müller einer der bekanntesten
köche in deutschland starkoch
fernsehkoch frank rosin und steffen
henssler müssen wir natürlich auch sein
restaurant besuchen das haben wir
gemacht viel spaß wir sind angekommen in
essen und mir gegenüber ist schon das
restaurant schote und direkte allererste
eindruck man sieht was se de also wie
die front gemacht ist mit dem licht
draußen das stimmt einen beim ersten
anblick schon direkt optimistisch
die an gewickelt mit einem piloten oben
drauf kommen können dann was wir nur
dazu machen
strammer max
wir sind gerade ein schritt im ressort
wirtschaft
sehr sehr lecker also das so schön
knusprig kommt alles super wundersamen
sinken auch die
textur im mund von einem echten wir aber
trotzdem ihren ganz eigenen geschmack so
durch die ihr durch den afrikanischen
wüstenstaat dankeschön das ist was
besonderes hier in dem moment wo du
herkommst noch mal kurz erster eindruck
von außen wunderschön von innen
wunderschön ganz überschaubar wenig
plätze hier wurden tolle empfang fand
ich also hat sich sehr sehr willkommen
gefühlt diese direkte ansprache das ist
direkt wieder was ist so das ist weniger
konservativ macht was so ein bisschen
entspannter alles macht nimmt direkt ein
bisschen die spannung raus man fühlt
sich direkt willkommen es ist auf
augenhöhe es ist einfach so ein also
mich spricht dass er an und wir müssen
immer mehr musik in das video legen ist
genau unsere lobby musik die werde immer
haben die wir lieben also ich würde
sagen der ton ist auf jeden fall gesetzt
für den sehr guten abend ohne dass wir
viel gegessen und eric hat auch alle
gesehen nelson müller himself bis heute
auch hier drin selbst am kochen
dementsprechend denke ich auch also wird
sagen eric wir stoßen wir mit unserem
alkoholfreien traubensaft mit sprudel
amt und starten den abend klein ich kein
problem
der bildhübsche präsentation also
wirklich ich habe mir noch nichts
gegessen werden auch probieren da ist
beim testen beim hessen mich wieder von
meinem ersten eindruck ein bisschen zu
lösen war der erste eindruck ist so gut
ist so neu ist auch die gesamte
einrichtung alles ist so dunkel weil
dick gehalten das einzige worauf das
licht scheint es das essen man hat den
fokus auf dem produkt und der focus darf
hier darauf seine spotlight soll darauf
es bildhübsche ich mache in der
reihenfolge ist erklärt bekommen
zunächst diese falsche windbeutel mit
geprüft und parmesan
ein herz auf der windbeutel definitiv
ein erstes mal für mich aber der strahl
zone wärme aus und er gibt ein wohliges
gefühl es geht los alter hat weiter geht
es mit dem knusperhäuschen mit kaviar
und tata wird hübsch angerichtet hier
mit der pinzette profi ob das
knusperhäuschen auch knuspert weil das
ist natürlich wichtig
ich hoffe das war eindeutig
also schulträger der textur unterschied
cremiger betrüger kaviar dazu dass tap
tap und dann diese knusprige hähnchen
geschmacklich und raum zehn prozent hier
die präsentation auch wieder ganz peschl
im eierbecher dieses altbekannte das ist
schon das eine oder andere mal begegnet
ist man geht mit einem löffel rhein hat
dann hier alles drauf trüffel lachs
drogen lachs blumenkohl muss
[Musik]
ich glaube wir haben vergessen wie schön
es sein kann oder mögliche dritte puppen
dieser cremige blumenkohl der salzige
fischen die platzenden fischen 10 15 für
die frau sprechen
die entspannung ist möglich direkt das
ist einfach so das ist einfach 65 sollen
holen das ist so viel gut einfach
sondern hier auch was los wird
gearbeitet hast nicht das gefühl du bist
du auf dem präsentierteller so schön
bisher ja wir haben ja eine entenleber
terrine mit champagner eis mit quitte
vorne haben wir an geröstetes mini
marios das schon schön goldbraun nicht
anlass probieren wir obst bevor es
auseinanderfällt
leber hat er ein eigenes
geschmacksprofil guter fertig was aber
gut aufgefangen und von diesen quitten
elementen die er so eine säure eingeben
man schmeckt die hochwertigkeit also es
ist einfach ultra-fans voll also das
merkt man wirklich
ultra cremig vollmundig das machen dass
man die terrine aufgegessen ist werden
wenn sich mal ein stück hier von den
driesch
[Musik]
patrick süß und bei schön angeröstet
aber auch nur auf einer seite die andere
seite das weniger angemessen aber das
erlaubt man extra unterschied in der
schweiz gut so ganz weitergeht sieht
jetzt sehr romantisch aus mit dieser
vorrichtung hier von der wir das essen
aber wir können es ganz einfach
herausnehmen und ein paar sich löffeln
werben kaviar wir haben ein buchweizen
chip ein viertes aigle und das wurde als
das wohlfühl gericht beschrieben ich
fühle mich auch schon wohl was jetzt
noch passieren vor allen dingen auch ein
gericht was immer auf der karte stehen
bleibt immer auf der karte nicht
schaffen jeder jahreszeit signature du
sagst das ganz genauso schön wie der
trotzdem kontrast geschaffen ist was ist
eigentlich relativ gleiche sein und
trotzdem was die grünen sie zu
verschönern
[Musik]
ich fühle mich wohl hier bleiben das
weiter erst
die ganzen komponenten kontrastieren
hier nicht mal so sehr sondern sie
verschmelzen einfach kann man zu einem
gaumenschmaus
das ist so gut als bisher ist alles nur
zehnter
ich habe für mich heute noch mal selbst
definiert die bewertungen die ich am
ende geht von null bis fünf sternen ist
für mich eine aussage darüber ob meine
erwartungen unter tropfen erreicht oder
übertroffen wurden genauso werde ich das
später auch bewerten wenn wir ganz
aufhören und man will das bisschen was
hier am ende wird man will das nicht so
da drin lassen und will sie rausholen
auf zum nächsten gang die kleinen
zwischen wangen nochmalig er sieht so
aus als würde dir noch was vertragen
wir machen das institut ja auch immer
ein thema in der show während der
pandemie ordentlich street gut verkauft
und es gibt einen kleinen kartoffeln hat
mit pool und sauna
diese politik ist sehr reich als klein
kontrast im kleinen tipp dazu
ausgedörrte schwein zudem wirke man es
die sicher varianten also zwischen
ahorn wäre
dann einfach noch mal an die meisten
afrika plötzlich ganz anders ja genau
das riecht doch schon selber
für mich ein bisschen was ab man braucht
davon ganz wenig gleich für den gangs
genug dass er im vorfeld schon einmal
probieren und den rest erklärt dann
gleich klargestellt
was meine ich dass du das jetzt erlebnis
das sind es durch so schön dass das
erste mal dass wir so eine berühmte
persönlichkeit die hinter dem restaurant
steht auch treffen ich finde dass tag
wasser aus und ganz wichtig wie immer
sind wir sehr subtil gewesen mit der
ankündigung dass wir drehen und die
wussten gar nicht dass wir jetzt kommen
also das ist nicht wegen und wenn man
das wäre sowieso gewesen unser kartoffel
donath untendrunter das
ein
bisschen trubel
ist gut sehr amerikanisiert das ganze
wenn ich das schon mal sagen
so eine schöne erfahrung super angenehm
und macht richtig spaß mal erlebt
richtig so ein netter typ so kommen
droht waren richtig sympathisch gemacht
und darauf freue ich jetzt mit den
händen mit den händen ist auch ein
echter download er hat auch noch wohin
ich war mir nicht ganz sicher ich
erwarte viel von diesem gericht erwarte
wirklich viel davon es riecht nach so
viel probleme
die uci war für jauch so erfrischend so
leute beschweren sich immer wenn ich
keinen helm tragen wenn wir in so einem
restaurant sind und bis dies doppelt zu
dumm aus wenn ein hemd trägt und zum
teil hier ist eine möglichkeit auf das
ist einfach schön so unkonventionell
wieder und es schmeckt so gut
die kirche zu krass was ist somani alter
alles ist da alles wird angesprochen
dass mein favorit bisher alles war
neunzehn dass er elf von 10 dazu dann
dieses schöne handtuch geisterbahn seit
langem konzert das sei deshalb brauchen
ja auch das fesch messer wunderschön
eingerichtet schöne kontraste auf den
teller außenrum hirse das war eine ganz
traurige soße sein der zerfällt hier bin
mir nicht sicher wie das anknüpfen wird
an diesem unfassbar geschmackvollen gang
von gerade eben probieren immer
also was in fisch betrifft schalten wir
merklichen gang zurück von der
intensität es aber trotz hartem ultra
liegt also weniger intensiv aber es
steht dem anderen ersten nicht unbedingt
ich hatte glaube ich noch nie so einen
perfekten daten fisch du hast auf diesem
sonnenbrillen strich hier auch so quasi
fünf eigene beilagen dazu jede
kombiniert auf eine andere art und weise
mit diesem perfekten zubereiteten fisch
der trotzdem sich ein bisschen
zurücknehmen finde ich so im vergleich
zu dem ganz nach vorn zu den
begleitenden speisen obwohl es auch eine
kleine portion pasta noch mal ein
bisschen mehr als alles andere ab zum
nächsten gericht wenn wir ein besonderes
stück von dem besonderen ente das ist
ganz saftig sein sollte zu haben wir
raten karamellisiertem rotkohl einen
topfenstrudel bin ordentlich soße
ausläufer der winter karte aber jetzt
bin ich gespannt wenn die entenbrust so
hoch angepriesen wird dann muss sie gut
sind
[Musik]
schmeckt intensiver und mehr nach unten
als alle endlich gegessen hat super
knusprig ist es dass das ist heftig die
soße dazu traum irgendwann ist der damen
aufgesprengt irgendwann kann ich nicht
mehr alles so genau eingehen weil man
ist gerade schon in so einer trance man
deswegen ja alle smartphones man hat
immer weiter gewesen ist immer weiter
perfekt geblieben auch das hier ist die
gleich probieren trockene spur ich
finde den ansatz auch geil dass sie dass
sie haben ja gesagt so in der soße
serviert weil man würde gerne mit viel
so fair ist und so ist es ja auch was es
gibt eine absolute 10 schon sehen und
dass es jetzt weiter genießen oder
kamera und dass das heer noch abwarten
[Musik]
wer hätte es gedacht dass das heer ist
ein weiteres highlight ist es eigentlich
noch ein highlight wenn alles rein
gar nicht aber nur übels hey das ist
deshalb hier so dunkel die ganzen
highlight sonst zu kraft also dass er
noch nie gold gegessen kennt man
natürlich von social media das auch
alles irgendwie blattgold auf weiß es
schmeckt nach nichts aber es ist schon
was besonderes das mal so auf den
tellern flammenbild mango würfel flammen
machen sich die mühe ihren familien
kleinen vertrauen und das in der mitte
muss auch ganz besonderes sein euch
recht
richtig
stark
daran es ist hier auch offen sich die 30
gewinne ich werde euch am ende das grand
total verraten was für webseiten aber
hier hat man wirklich das gefühl dann
kriegt das wieder hier sind sehr viele
sehr exklusive verschiedene
schokoladensorten verarbeitet
die bewertung von bisher fällt meistens
ein bisschen kürzer aus weil davor ist
schon so viel gesagt worden es passiert
immer so viel ist es so groß ist großes
erlebnis was man runterbrechen muss
hierzu können sich so vieles das
unfassbare gehabt aber ich genieße es
mit dem wir sehen uns gleich zum
ergebnis
[Musik]
ich
war krank kaiser zwar eine andere welt
das war perfektion mehr ist das war
perfektion de gab zurück nach köln ich
werde das glaube ich mit ein bisschen
mehr zeit noch viel besser verstehen
warum das du geil war wir sehen uns
gleich wir sind jetzt ein zwei tage
vergangen ich habe viel darüber
nachgedacht das ist meine bewertung dass
der besuch in müllers schotter ein
besonderer sein sollte wurde schon beim
betreten des kleinen und stilvoll
eingerichteten lokals ersichtlich die
begrüßung und der erste gruß aus der
küche erfolgten im stehen ein
unkonventioneller weg der direkt zeigt
dass man hier außerhalb der norm denkt
das spiegelt sich auch im essen
interessante kombination welche zu
keinem zeitpunkt erzwungen wird einfach
lecker aufmerksamer service und ein chef
der mit anpackt kurzum einer der besten
restaurantbesuche die ich bisher erleben
durfte selbst gehören heute was soll ich
dazu noch sagen es war einfach
geisteskrank
[Musik]